[Music]  baby  you don't know what you're saying what  brings you down then i'm studying london  college of fashion  room is on the top floor it's perfect i  love it  i could live any place in any time i'd  live here in london  in the 60s  last night  i saw something in my dreams  [Music]  there was a girl  you are  [Music]  i sandy this kind of gift  i can see people faces  things others can't do it this is the  closest most people ever get to their  dreams  [Music]  [Music]  what did you see  [Music]  do you believe in ghosts  [Applause]  you witnessed the murder last night but  you believe this was a vision from the  past  the guy that killed her is to like that  i have to stop him  you can have to be more specific love  you can't save me  you